The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, so you might
recall we had a snow day,
and the snow day bumped us.
We interrupted our
introduction theme
and dove right into
data collection.
Then we did
short-range planning.
So Neema was lecturing
that over two lectures.
Now we're back to the third
and last introductory material.
And then we'll go back and
do more data and modeling
if that makes sense.
Sorry for that interruption.
So it's a little more general
than the other classes
that we've seen.
And today's topic is model
capacities and costs.
So we'll cover a simple capacity
analysis that you might do,
you know, back of the
envelope calculation.
If somebody is asking
you about something,
and it's a completely
new service,
and you just want
to have an idea,
I will give an example of that.
Then we'll look at
worldwide status
of urban rail systems,
both heavy rail
and light rail, some bus ways.
And we'll look at capital
and operating costs
at a high level, focusing more
on the US using the National
Transit Database.
All right, so
first slide here is
an update of the statistics
I gave you earlier.
So you have these
statistics from
the previous
introductory lecture,
but these are updated for 2013.
So I'm not going to
cover this in detail.
But if you want to compare
with the previous table,
you can do so.
And here you have
more updated numbers.
These come from
the APTA Fact Book,
and they take the numbers from
the National Transit Database.
And let's start with that
simple capacity analysis.
So this is a
theoretical exercise,
but it gives you some idea
of how one might approach--
if you have nothing
to go on, how
one might approach
estimating what capacity
you need for some service.
So the problem is, given
a pie-shaped sector
into the central
business district served
by a single transit line, what
will be the peak passenger
flow entering the central
business district.
And that might give you an
idea of what mode you need.
Right?
Can you run a bus system?
Do you need a light rail,
a BRT, a heavy rail?
So it gives you some idea.
And you might have
some statistics
about the city where
you're being asked about,
the question.
And so you can make
some assumptions.
You can draw this on the back
of a napkin and, you know,
do some calculus with
it if you want to.
And that's what
we're going to do.
So I'm going to draw on
the board a little bit.
What do we have here?
Yeah, I'll draw the same
shape here for reference.
So we have a cone-shaped
sector or a pie-shaped sector.
And there's some angle
of that corridor, which
is the catchment area
over which people
might walk to the service.
The service, by the
way, is along some line,
and it reaches the city center,
which we're calling the CBD.
And at that center, there is
some density, some population
density, which we call
P sub c, the population
density at the center.
And at any point along this
pie or pie-shaped sector,
this, the length of
this arc, is r theta,
where theta is the angle, and
r is the radius from the CBD
up to that point.
So r is a variable,
and it starts at 0,
and it extends all the
way up to the length
of the corridor,
which is L. L is
the maximum value r can take.
Does that make sense?
Everybody following?
OK, and then we take little
slices of these arcs.
And they have a very, very thin,
infinitesimally small width,
dr. And we can--
that sort of sets the stage
for what we want to do here.
Let's assume something.
Let's start assuming the
population density, which
starts at a very high level
in the center of the business
district, starts
dropping as you move out.
That makes sense.
Right?
In most cities,
that's what happens.
We're going to assume
that it drops linearly
and that it reaches some value
lower than Pc at some distance
L from the CBD.
And if we look at the
distance from the CBD
here, which we call r, and we
start at 0, 0 is at the CBD.
Right?
We start with a
population density of Pc.
And we're going to assume it
drops linearly to some amount.
And at some point,
we'll reach L.
And that's where we
stop the corridor.
So this part doesn't really
matter because the corridor
doesn't serve the part.
And the rate at which that
population density declines,
we will call delta P.
OK, so total population
density is decreasing as we
move outwards from the center.
All right, so let's
start with what is
the population in the corridor.
Right?
Because we need to know how many
people are in that corridor.
And then from that,
we can calculate,
based on some assumptions,
how many people
might access that line.
So we'll start with
calculating the population
in that whole pie-shaped sector.
All right, so call
it population.
So we'll take an integral from
r equals 0 to r equals L, which
is the length of the corridor.
And we take r theta, which is
the length of this arc, which
it starts very small and gets
longer and longer until we
get to this part,
which is L theta alone.
Right?
So this is the arc length.
And we multiply by the
arc width, which is dr.
population density.
And the population
density is a function
of how far we are
from the center.
So that's going to be P of r.
And we can call
this graph P of r.
The y value here is P of r.
It starts at Pc, drops to 0.
Or before reaching--
well, yeah, it
doesn't get to 0 at the
point of reaching L. Right?
So it remains positive
throughout the length
of the corridor.
All right, and now we can
just, you know, do some math
and calculate this.
So I'll just run through it.
So we have r theta dr. Let's
substitute this function, which
is the population density.
We assume that it
had this shape.
So let's plug that in here.
It's a linear function.
So it starts at the
center with a high number,
and it decreases as a function
of r at a rate of dP and times
r.
Right?
So when r equals 0,
there's no decrease.
As you move this way,
you multiply r times dP,
and you get the
difference between Pc
and the point where you are.
All right, here I'm just
going to collect terms to make
things look a little nicer.
All right, so again, we're just
distributing this times that
and that times that.
So we have now two integrals.
We can take some constants out.
So theta is a constant,
and Pc is a constant.
So we can take those
out of the integral.
And we continue
integrating from 0 to L.
But now we have a
simple thing, r dr,
which we know how to integrate.
And then here, dr is--
sorry, dP is given.
So we have an assumption
about what that rate is right
so dP is taken out as
well as a constant.
And we, again, integrate
from 0 through L. And sorry,
and theta is also constant.
Right?
So we can take that out.
And we have r squared dr.
So now it looks a
lot simpler, and we
can do the simple integral.
Right?
Integral of r dr is
r squared over 2.
Integral of r squared
is r cubed over 3.
So we can substitute that in.
So we have Pc theta
over 2 times r squared--
and r squared goes from 0 to L--
minus dP theta over 3.
And we have r cubed
going from 0 to L.
And now we just simplify things,
and we compute the going from 0
to L on both sides.
So we are left with Pc theta
over 2 times L squared.
When these ranges are 0, this
term is 0, and that term is 0.
So all that matters is plugging
in-- substituting L for r.
Right?
And the terms of minus 0 are 0.
So we don't need to write them.
dP theta over 3 L cubed--
and just collecting terms,
the ones that look similar--
Pc/2 minus dP L/3.
OK, so this is the
population in the corridor.
And it's a function of the
properties of the corridor.
Right?
So if the corridor
is longer, then we
have a higher population.
If the angle of the corridor
gets wider [INAUDIBLE]
population in the corridor.
That also makes sense.
And then it also depends on the
population of the city center--
the higher it is, the bigger
the population in the center.
And it depends on the rate at
which the population decreases
from the center--
the smaller the
rate of decrease,
the larger the population.
Right?
Does that make sense?
OK, and now, in terms
of peak passenger flow,
we can look at units, but we'll
have to add some assumptions.
So actually, I
think, at this point,
I can probably stop
the math on the board
and just go straight to it.
So this is the modeling part.
And now we're just going to
make some assumptions about--
given that the population in the
corridor and some assumptions
about what L and
theta and Pc and dP
are and some assumptions about
the share of those people that
would take transit, we'll look
at what the peak passenger
flow is.
So let's go straight to it.
Here we have the
variables that I
defined on the board and
some additional ones.
We have t, c, m, and p.
Right?
So t is the number of one-way
trips per person per day.
We're going to have
to assume this.
c is the share of trips
that are inbound to the CBD,
as opposed to going outbound.
Right?
So it's what
percentage go inbound.
m is the transit market
share for CBD-bound trips.
So some people will take
cars or other modes.
And we want to have some
assumption about what
percent of people that
are going into the CBD
will take transit, as
opposed to other modes.
So that's m.
And p is the share of CBD-bound
transit trips in the peak hour.
So we want the peak hour flow.
And maybe we don't
want the whole day.
We just want peak hour flow.
So there's going to be
some percentage of that.
So here you have
the same equations
that I have on the board.
And the peak
passenger flow is what
we have there, which is the
population in the corridor
multiplied by our four
assumptions, our four
factors that are
going to convert
the population in
the whole corridor
to what percent of people are
going to go into the CBD taking
transit.
Again, this is a very
simple, theoretical exercise,
but it could be
useful at some point.
And we'll just plug
in for two examples.
We have two scenarios
here-- one where
the population density in the
CBD is 10,000 and another one
where it's 20,000.
For reference, in New York
City, the population density
is about 28,000.
So these are not as high
as those very dense cities.
AUDIENCE: But like what
is 10,000 [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: Depends how--
again, it's the same thing.
Like it depends how
far you go and what
you define as the center.
But here are some numbers.
This could be some city.
Right?
These are typical
of some cities.
So here we have some
decreases and the rate
of decrease in the population
from the center going out.
We're assuming a 40-degree
angle for the shape of this.
If you have a
city, you know, you
have several lines
going in radially.
This transit corridor serves
about a 40-degree angle.
So--
AUDIENCE: Is that--
that seems like a lot.
PROFESSOR: It is a lot.
AUDIENCE: Like maybe
a little too much.
PROFESSOR: Well, it
depends how many--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 40
degrees like in the inner part,
but, you know, 40 degrees
you go [INAUDIBLE] miles out.
Now you're already making
a [INAUDIBLE] arch.
PROFESSOR: At the end,
it sounds like a lot,
but, at the beginning,
not so much.
If you think of a city,
you know, and you have--
these are 90 degree angles.
Right, and you add
two more lines.
That's 45.
So we're how many lines
would you have in a city?
And it sort-- right?
So it's not that unrealistic
to think of some line
with a 40-degree angle coming
into the CBD from outside.
And we're assuming a
10-mile length and factors--
so here we have 2.5,
0.2, 0.5, and 0.25.
So that's the assumptions
for the different constants
to convert the whole population
into the number of people
going inbound in the
morning rush taking transit.
All right, so if
we plug that in,
we get a required capacity of
10,000 in the first scenario
and 30,000 in the
other scenario.
And then from that,
one could say, well,
can I have a bus system
serving 10,000 people per hour?
Or can I have a bus
system or a rail system
serving 30,000 people per hour.
That's accommodating a
flow, which this is, again,
a back-of-the-napkin
calculation,
but it gives you an idea of,
based on the characteristics
of some city, what
we would need.
So let's look at some
theoretical capacities now.
So in this slide, we
are looking at kind
of high-end, upper bounds
almost on these modes.
So for rail, let's
assume a very long train,
which is 10 cars long, and it's
packed with 200 people per car.
And it runs at a high
frequency, every two minutes.
That gives you 60,000
passengers per hour.
So that's about as
much as a metro system
can provide in terms of
capacity or a line, metro
line, a single metro line.
If we look at bus, so a
full bus, 70 passengers,
that's quite packed.
You could run, if you
have multiple bays,
you could run
30-second headways.
So if you see, BRT corridors
have capacity to do that.
Obviously, if they are queuing
up to serve a single stop,
that could not happen.
But if you have multiple
bays, that can happen.
So based on that assumption,
you can get 8,400.
All right, so that's
pushing the limits of bus.
BRT-- BRT vehicles are longer.
So you might fit
200 people in one
of these double-articulated
vehicles.
You might have even 20-second
headways with good facilities.
That gives you 36,000
passengers per hour, again,
pushing the limits here.
Light rail, I have
to say that I'm
assuming a two-car
train here, but we
could have three-car train.
So maybe I'm not
pushing the limits
as much on light rail here.
But based on a two-car train
assumption and 150 passengers
per car, which is quite a
bit for a light rail car,
and assuming one-minute
headway, that's
18,000 passengers per hour.
Right?
So you can compare these.
And again, these are all
kind of upper bounds.
Maybe light rail can be
pushed a little higher.
But it gives you an idea of what
the theoretical capacities are.
So now we have this
back-of-the-envelope
calculation--
10,000, 30,000.
And what would we
need for 10,000?
Could we serve that
10,000 demand with a bus?
Probably not.
Do we need rail,
BRT, or light rail?
Probably so.
So it gives you an idea.
And if it's the 30,000
example, well, it
looks like we're
going to need rail.
Right?
Because BRT is kind of--
you're getting to
the high end of that.
So we're probably going
to need rail for that.
OK, and now let's look at
what happens here in Boston.
So it's much lower
here, nowhere near
the theoretical
capacities, right,
that we're talking about.
These are peak-hour volumes
for the different lines.
So if we look at the Red Line,
which is the most crowded line,
in the Cambridge section,
which is the most crowded,
especially between Central
Square and MIT-- actually,
that's the highest
point on the system--
we have almost 10,000 people
per hour, passengers per hour.
AUDIENCE: We saw in
a different course--
one of the people
from the T who came
who was a graduate
of the MST program
showed slightly higher
numbers than that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so these
numbers are a little dated.
And it depends on how
you define the peak hour.
And you know, I could show
you the peak 15 minutes,
and that would be higher
than this, for example.
So if you look at the peak--
yeah, like the peak of the peak,
it's even higher than this.
But it still is the case that
these are not approaching
the theoretical capacities.
And that's because we
don't have, you know,
two-minute headways and
10-car trains or yeah.
So right, so the Orange Line,
we have two sections here,
the north and the
southwest, similar numbers.
Blue Line is slightly lower.
On the Green Line, the branches
do about, you know, 1,800,
less than 2,000 each.
So we're looking at a much
lower number than the light rail
theoretical capacity.
And in the central subway
where all these branches merge,
we get a much higher demand,
but it's still lower.
Again, these vehicles are
not running every minute.
And in some cases, they
are, but not consistently.
And we don't fill
all the vehicles,
you know, to crush
load for a whole hour.
Right?
So we're not getting
that capacity.
We're not delivering
So it gives you an
idea where we are.
If you've used the
system here in Boston,
you might relate taking
the train at peak hour
to what these numbers
look like and think
about what it would take to
increase capacity in terms
of more cars or a
higher demand spread
over a longer peak
and things like that.
OK, now let's look at
worldwide urban rail systems.
This is metro, and I have
grouped it by continent.
And it starts sort
of before the 1900s.
And you can see the earlier
systems started in Europe--
London, Budapest.
Right?
And then North America
followed closely after that.
Boston takes the prize
for the first subway.
That's the Green Line.
And even though we call
it light rail here,
we're calling it
metro in the slide.
So we have a few starts
in North America,
and it sort of falls
flat in 1920s and 1930s.
And then it takes off again--
1960s all the up.
It keeps increasing.
Asia was a little
slower to start,
but it's going up really fast.
China is building
a lot of metro.
Africa, I think it has
two systems right now.
And there are no systems that
I am aware of in Australia,
but they are building
one that should
start before the end of
this decade in Sydney.
So they're going
forward with that.
So this is, you know--
you can see that
we're building metro
and that it goes
together with what
we said on the first class.
Population is increasing.
And especially urban
population is increasing.
People are moving away from
rural areas into cities.
The required capacities to
have agglomeration benefits
and avoid traffic and
air pollution problems
is requiring higher density,
higher flow systems like metro.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: So you've got
Australia has some very
dense cities of course.
How do they move people in?
Like do they have BRT systems?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so they have BRT.
They have light rail.
AUDIENCE: Melbourne has
the longest light rail
network in the world.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and they
have pretty good BRT.
AUDIENCE: The bulk of Melbourne
is electric commuter trains
that operate at sort of
subway-level headways.
So it wouldn't be
included in your--
PROFESSOR: So yeah, we're
not counting them here.
And so good point,
it's hard to--
there are many ways of
accounting for systems here.
Sometimes, you know--
AUDIENCE: Commuter
rail and heavy rail.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that might be mixed.
Or do they count
those as two or as one
if there are different
systems in one city?
I've tried here to count
each city as one system,
even if there are
multiple systems.
So for example, I'm not
counting the Tube in London
and Docklands Light
Railway as two systems.
I'm counting them as one.
But some people would
count them as two.
So there is some
arbitrary choice
to be made here in
accounting, but it gives you
an idea of what the trends
are and how we are moving
and how it started and
where we are right now.
Here's light rail, light
rail and streetcar.
So if we only looked
at light rail,
it wouldn't look like this.
This includes
streetcars, and that's
why we start so early before
the 1900s in Europe and Asia
as well.
And then North America really
didn't follow until much
more recently.
AUDIENCE: Well, North America,
it's like [INAUDIBLE]..
If you include North America,
every city had streetcars.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but they're
not operating right now.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but they're
not currently operating.
AUDIENCE: You would
see [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so that's right.
So that's another good point.
So if we included things
that were operating
and no longer dropped,
then this graph would go up
and then down.
And these are
based on statistics
of currently-operating systems
that started at some point
in the past.
Right?
So that's a good point.
Thank you for bringing that up.
And we see here Africa,
Oceania, so Australia--
and let's see.
Yeah, Africa, South
America, and Australia
don't have many systems.
Right?
So mainly, we have
[INAUDIBLE] in Asia,
and increasingly so
in North America,
but not at the same
level as in Asia.
Obviously, that has to do
with the size of the cities
and the number of
large cities as well.
So OK, capital costs, so
these are based, once more,
on the NTD numbers, the
National Transit Database.
These are 2013 numbers that were
published in the 2015 APTA Fact
Book.
And you can download
that on Stellar
if you want to look
at these in detail.
So $18.2 billion was
spent in capital costs,
and we're going to look at
how that cost was distributed.
So if we look at by type,
about a quarter of that
was spent on purchasing vehicles
or rehauling old vehicles
for their midlife repair.
And about 60% was spent on
infrastructure and facilities.
All right, so that could include
new rail lines or extensions,
repairs of those, bus stops,
maintenance facilities, right,
offices, things like that.
And then about 15%, 16%
was spent on other things.
Those other things could be
AFC systems, other things that
are not vehicles or facilities.
Right?
So OK, by mode,
about a quarter was
spent on bus projects, about
35% on heavy rail projects,
and then less, a little less,
on commuter rail and light rail,
and then 5% in other modes.
And that's mostly paratransit
or demand responsive, as they
[INAUDIBLE] APTA Fact Book.
So it gives you an idea of
how the US, on any given year,
distributes the
capital expenditures.
You might think that,
from year to year,
these costs vary a lot because
capital investments are
very lumpy.
Right?
You don't have them,
and, all of a sudden,
you invest a lot of
money into a system.
But because there
are so many cities,
they don't actually
vary that much.
And the other reason
that doesn't happen
is because a lot of the
expenditures are gradual.
So it takes several
years to build new lines.
So they are distributed
over several years,
instead of all at once.
And here we have the
breakdown by mode and type
at the same time.
So about-- the key takeaway
here is so $4.5 billion
was spent on bus projects.
And about half of that was
on vehicles and about half
was on facilities, the
repair facilities, bus stops,
things of that nature.
When we look at rail, the
percent spent on vehicles
is much lower.
It's about 10% to 20%,
7% to 20% in this case,
depending on the
specific rail mode.
And closer to 90% is spent on
infrastructure and facilities.
That makes sense.
Right?
You have to lay--
you have to sort of put rail.
You have to build stations.
The maintenance yards
are more expensive.
So these are bigger projects.
To the extent that the
right of way is a subway,
then you have to dig.
And so it's very expensive.
And here you have the total
expenditure, capital cost
by mode.
And so 4.5 on bus, 6.2 on
heavy rail, 3 on commuter rail,
3.5 on light rail.
OK, and now focusing on
infrastructure costs,
so what drives the
infrastructure costs?
First, the type of
construction, right,
so if we look at
heavy rail, you could
build at grade, so
leveled on the street
or on sort of new
lands that you don't
have to acquire from anyone.
That's the least expensive.
Then you move to elevated.
If you have to go
over streets, and you
have an elevated section, that's
the second most expensive.
And then subway tends to
be the most expensive.
And there are two
ways of doing that.
There's cut and cover.
So that's a shallow tunnel.
You dig a hole.
You put the rail lines, and then
you build a roof on top of it,
and cars drive over it.
That's shallow tunnel.
And then there's deep tunnel,
which is the most expensive.
That tends to be with a
tunnel boring machine.
So you get these huge
machines that drill the hole.
They're very fun to
learn about and look it.
I encourage you to YouTube them.
And they are usually
built for the project.
And when they
finish digging, they
are sort of taken off course.
And they sort of remain
interred at the level.
So they're kind of used
once, and there you go.
So London has used a lot of
these for their very deep Tube.
And yeah, you should
look at these on YouTube.
AUDIENCE: In New York,
it's kind of common.
Right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: It basically
goes along the avenues.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so in
London, we have both.
Right?
So the earlier lines like
the Central Line and the--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
Circle and District.
PROFESSOR: The Circle
and District Lines
are definitely cut and cover.
And then the Silver
Line is very deep.
Right?
And so that's a
tunnel boring machine.
AUDIENCE: Can you give a
sense of the difference
between let's say at grade,
elevated, and shallow and deep?
PROFESSOR: Maybe I should
have shown some pictures.
But at grade is just
at street level.
AUDIENCE: No, I know, but
like the difference in cost.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Like cost per mile.
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'll
give some examples
in the next few slides.
Yeah, that's a good segue.
So the other key factors are
land acquisition and clearance.
So if you're
building a new line,
and you have to use eminent
domain and sort of buy property
from people who own them,
who own that property,
to build your new line,
that costs some money.
Also, the number, size,
complexity, and length
of the stations--
so station design is
a key component here
and the complexity
of the system.
Is this an independent line?
Or are there many
points of transfer?
And how do you coordinate that?
During construction, do
you have to keep operating
some parts of the line?
How do you manage that?
So if you look at, for
example, the repair
of the bridge, the Longfellow
Bridge here in Boston,
we wanted to do that with rail,
for the most part, running.
So that has increased the
costs of that project.
You couldn't just take the
bridge down and rebuild it.
And we wouldn't have the
Red Line for a long time.
OK, so here are
some typical costs.
Here are some, four examples.
Right?
And they vary a lot,
but it gives you
some idea of the
magnitude of these costs.
So Tren Urbano was one of
the most recent systems.
It was built in 2002 in
San Juan, Puerto Rico.
And it 50% at grade,
about 40% elevated,
and 10% subway, just a small
section that was subway.
It cost about $2
billion to build.
And if you divide that by
the length of the corridor,
it comes out to $118
million per kilometer.
Right?
So it gives you an
idea of what it takes.
The MBTA Red Line in
1984, it was extended
to Alewife from Harvard.
And that was 5 kilometer
extension, four stations.
It was all subway.
So it cost $0.6 billion
of $600 million.
And that comes up to $120
million per kilometer.
All these figures are in the
dollar numbers of the year
that they were built. They're
not adjusted for inflation.
Then we have the
Los Angeles MTA.
That was a new system
started in the late 1980s.
It was all subway, 7 kilometers.
$1.2 billion comes
out to $180 million
per kilometer, so same
range, right, or similar.
I mean, obviously, from 120
to 180, it's 60 million.
That's a lot of money,
but same ballpark,
same order of magnitude.
WMATA was cheaper on
a unit cost basis.
It was built over several
decades, multiple phases, 100
kilometers, so lots of stations,
lots of distance covered.
It's a mix of subway,
elevated, and at grade.
And it cost $6.4 billion, and
that comes out to $60 million
per kilometer.
So yeah.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can you say
what is WMATA again.
PROFESSOR: WMATA is the
Washington metro, Washington,
DC.
AUDIENCE: Washington, DC.
PROFESSOR: Washington, DC, yeah.
Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
So since this--
PROFESSOR: In one year.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So since this remains
the same across years--
PROFESSOR: More or less.
It varies, but it
doesn't vary drastically
is what I wanted to say.
AUDIENCE: So would that
mean that in fact we're
declining the amount we spend
on transportation because this
is not inflation adjusted?
PROFESSOR: This is not
inflation adjusted.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: So it's
the [INAUDIBLE]
are declining, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: For heavy rail, yes.
Yeah, maybe, yeah.
We're building a lot of
light rail and stuff.
But there is still some
expansion or repair or--
AUDIENCE: Does this mean
the Second Avenue subway
extension isn't in the
same order of magnitude
as any other--
PROFESSOR: I'm not familiar
with the unit costs for that.
AUDIENCE: I read it was like
$2 billion per kilometer.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I mean
it depends on many things.
So--
AUDIENCE: Well,
so recent lines, I
mean Seattle was
about $1 billion per.
And San Francisco Central
Subway was about $1 billion per.
So modern subways
are-- the stupid GLX,
the Tremont extension
was $500 million
because the T can't procure
a project out of their butts,
but it's still still
four times cheaper
than Second Avenue subway.
Well, but it's also
being built at grade,
and it gets the right of way.
PROFESSOR: So many
factors there.
Let's look at light rail now.
So LA MTA, 30 kilometers at
grade, so a long distance,
but all at grade--
$690 million, this includes
stations and vehicles.
That comes to $23
million per kilometer.
So you can see that these
costs are a lot lower.
A lot of that has to do with
it being at grade and also
not being as
complex of a system.
Yeah, you have a question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, are these
costs for just the parts
that were built in the late
1980s and not over time.
Like the most recent one
is not included in that.
PROFESSOR: Not including
the most recent ones,
that's correct, yeah.
So Buffalo, 10
kilometers, but subway,
cost almost the
same, even though it
was a third of the length.
It comes out to $53
million per kilometer.
Santa Clara, 30
kilometers at grade,
so very similar to LA MTA,
about $500 million, $16 million
per kilometer.
So you can see that,
even in similar systems,
there are other details
that might affect cost
significantly.
And then Portland, mid
1980s, 24 kilometers
at grade, $214 million, about
$9 million per kilometer-- so
that was the cheapest of these
examples on a unit cost basis.
AUDIENCE: Remind us what a
light rail subway is again.
PROFESSOR: So yeah, these
are terms that are arbitrary,
but our stereotypical definition
that we are using here
is a lot of it tends to
be at grade, not always.
It could be subway.
It tends to have electricity
from pickup lines on the top.
You might have some sections
where people board sort
of straight from the streets.
All right, so there is not
a special platform where--
like a subway station where
people tap into a gate
and move in.
AUDIENCE: This is not that.
PROFESSOR: Right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Light rail subway.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So--
AUDIENCE: People are
walking into the--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so when
we look at heavy rail,
we're thinking about
things like the Red Line
and the Blue Line and
the Orange Line here.
When we look at
light rail, we're
thinking more like streetcars
and the Green Line here
in Boston.
Right?
So the Green Line is
more like light rail.
Even though it has
the subway portion,
it's operating like a light
rail in some part, subway part.
Yeah, but if we look
at other countries,
some systems are
called light rail.
Docklands Light Rail
in London, false--
if we describe it,
we would classify it
as heavy rail with
these descriptions.
And in Asia, we see
a lot of systems
called light rail, which are, by
these descriptions, heavy rail.
So the terms are
used with caution.
OK, busways, so the South Boston
Transitway was 2 kilometers.
That was the Silver Line tunnel,
right, cost $606 million--
that does include the
purchase of vehicles--
and so $303, of course,
million per kilometer.
TransMilenio was 36 kilometers
at grade in the early 2000s,
$200 million, $5
million per kilometer.
Seattle, 2 kilometer
of bus tunnel, $319--
$160.
So the takeaway here is,
if you're making a tunnel,
you can see that the first and
third examples are tunnels.
Right?
And they cost a lot more in
the hundreds of millions.
And the three that are
at grade, second, fourth,
and fifth examples, two of
them in the 36, 35 kilometer,
and this one a
little shorter, are
in the two-digit, single-digit
million dollars per kilometer.
AUDIENCE: TransMilenio,
you're talking
about like the first, initial--
PROFESSOR: Because
they've kept growing
is what you're saying, right?
I don't know--
I don't remember what range of
years this includes exactly.
But yeah, I'm saying,
you know, whatever
they were sort of starting
to operate in 2001.
Yeah.
And you can see here
36 kilometers at grade.
So we could then go
look and see what
is that 36 kilometers
at grade that they
built around 2001 to see.
If they've expanded
more recently,
that's probably
not included here.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
So these are examples to give
you an idea of what it costs
or what it has cost.
OK, generic costs
for rail, so it
costs from about
$2 to $2.5 million
per car for a heavy rail train.
So if you calculate what
capacity you need, and you
think you need a
fleet of 200 vehicles,
you can take these numbers
and multiply by $2.5 million.
You have some idea
of how much it
costs to purchase your fleet.
Some recent-- a recent CNR,
it was a large procurement.
And that helps bring
the unit cost down.
So 284 cars replaced Orange
and Red Line vehicles.
Siemens in 2010, it was
about $2.3 million per car.
That was for 94 Blue Line cars.
Then we have Hyundai
Rotem, $2.3 million
per car-- these are
75 commuter rail cars,
rather than heavy rail cars.
Breda, $2 million per car--
these are the Green Line
cars, 95 of them.
And the last example are
locomotives for commuter rail,
$5.7 million per locomotive.
So they cost more, but these
are not all passenger cars.
These are the locomotives
for the commuter rail system.
And for bus, so a
standard bus, a CNG bus,
the Compressed
Natural Gas, these
are, again, recent MBTA orders--
the generic cost, $300,000,
$350,000 about per bus.
There was an order
to NABI, and it
was for 300 vehicles in 2004.
And that was $320,000 per bus.
Trolley, 40-foot trolley is
about $1 million per trolley.
These are the sort of electric
Silver Line vehicles I think.
I'm pretty sure.
The articulated, 60-foot CNG
buses, 44 vehicles in 2003,
and the articulated,
dual-mode, 60-foot buses--
this is Silver Line, the
one that runs in the tunnel
and goes out to the airport--
$1.6 million, 32 vehicles, 2004.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe this
is already happening,
but is there any move
for different transport
organizations to
consolidate their designs
and like be able to reuse
vehicle design and bus design?
Like why are there separate
things for all cities?
PROFESSOR: That's a good
question, but a lot of it
is cultural.
There are-- so for
example, Green Line here
has sort of specific needs with
respect to like turning radius,
and they have a lot of steep
grades in some sections.
They're also used to a
certain type of vehicle.
So they're more
comfortable procuring
vehicles that are similar to
what they've had in the past.
So there's some resistance to
trying something very new all
of a sudden.
But there are some vehicles
that are very common, especially
in newer systems.
And they tend to be
a little cheaper.
So yeah, if you
can get big orders,
or if you're a small
system, and you
can partner with someone
else when they are procuring
to procure additional
vehicles-- instead
of you doing 10 yourself,
you add yourself
to an order of 100.
You get a lower price.
So yeah?
AUDIENCE: But then
there's certainly
two examples of that in
streetcars, the most recent
one, which was when the Boston
and San Francisco bought
a similar design for
streetcars in the '70s,
and both got a crappy product.
But 50 years before when the
PCC cars, the ones that still
run down in Mattapan, was a
sort of standardized streetcar
design over most of the country,
and that worked really well.
So it has been done, but--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and
still is done, I think.
Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: But each system, I
think, has so many [INAUDIBLE]
things.
But when it comes
to buses, then you
do see the same types of
buses like in many systems.
In Europe, you only
have like two or three
manufacturers that
make them all.
In the US, as well.
PROFESSOR: And big procurements,
not so much for bus,
but for rail, a lot
of big procurements
have rules requiring
local manufacturing.
So yeah, you get a Chinese
company to do the latest--
where was that example--
CNR, right, but I'm pretty sure
that a lot of the manufacture
is happening in
Massachusetts or close by.
So OK, typical capital
costs per passenger mile,
so looking at a
range of examples,
it will cost [INAUDIBLE] going
anywhere from $0.05 to $0.10.
So if you have--
again, if you're doing
the napkin calculation
on a new system or new line,
you might think how many
passenger miles do I have.
You could multiply by this to
figure out how much you could
expect to spend on vehicles.
And for infrastructure, that
could range anywhere from $0.01
to $1 because there are so
many ways of doing this.
Right?
It could be a subway.
It could be at grade.
It could be a bus.
Or it could be rail.
So it's very variable, and you
need to get into the specifics.
OK, now let's look
at operating costs.
We've been talking
about capital costs.
Let's look at operating costs.
So in the US in 2013,
we spent $42.2 billion
across the industry.
And if we divide that
by type, about 44%
was spent in vehicle
operations, and the rest of it
was more or less evenly
distributed between vehicle
maintenance, other
kinds of maintenance
like facility maintenance,
administration,
and purchased transportation.
Purchased transportation is
when a public agency outsources
the operation of some mode.
Most of this 14% is paratransit,
so on-demand transportation
for the handicapped
and other groups.
Some of it is commuter rail.
So for example, the MBTA
operates commuter rail
through a third party.
All right, OK, by mode, about
half is spent on buses--
makes sense because there are
more bus systems and, even
in cities that have
rail, but the bus systems
are quite large, and
they cover a wide area--
about 20% on heavy
rail, 13% commuter rail,
and much less on light rail.
Paratransit is about
12%, 3% for other modes.
Other modes is things like
ferries and other modes not
included in the traditional
bus, heavy rail, commuter
rail, light rail.
So OK, and let's
look at vehicles--
sorry, employees
per running vehicle.
So by mode, how many
employees would you
have to have to operate,
to run a system?
So paratransit, about
1.6 per vehicle--
obviously, you have one person
driving a paratransit vehicle.
That person has an
eight-hour shift,
and you run that vehicle
for a longer time.
So you need more
people than vehicles.
Bus tends to be higher
because bus systems tend
to start much earlier and
end service much later.
And you also have maintenance
yards and refueling facilities.
Right?
So you have bus stops to clean.
So it's a more
intense operation.
Commuter rail, 4.7-- you
have the people driving
the locomotives.
You have the attendants
looking at tickets.
You have rail to maintain
and stations to maintain.
So that's commuter rail.
Heavy rail is 5.5.
Again, it starts
early, runs late.
You have a lot of stations to
maintain, more so than commuter
rail, so 5.5.
Light rail is 6.8.
Part of the recent light rail
is high is because many systems
have one driver per car.
Or some systems, at least,
So here in the Green
Line, we have that.
Right?
So if you have a two-car
train, you have two drivers.
And again, it starts service
early, ends service late.
So you [INAUDIBLE].
You need multiple shifts
to run the whole day.
And you have
maintenance of stations.
Light rail stations [INAUDIBLE]
be shorter than heavy rail.
So they have more
stations to take care of.
And then there's maintenance,
vehicle maintenance
and facility maintenance.
[INAUDIBLE] is about three
employees per vehicle.
OK, so comparing, these numbers
below are from a 1970 study
on employees per vehicle.
And it's a comparison
of bus and rail.
So what's neat about the
comparison at the bottom
is that we are distributing
the costs of a vehicle
not only by mode, but also
by what type of expense.
Right?
So at the top, we're
saying bus is this much.
Here we divide it by vehicle
operation i.e. driving,
vehicle maintenance,
management and control,
fare collection,
way maintenance,
and then you have
the total number.
So it is from an earlier study.
But for vehicle maintenance,
it's more or less the same
on a unit cost basis.
For bus, this is per car,
and that's per vehicle.
So you have about 2.2 drivers
per bus for bus systems,
about 1 for rail systems.
This is driving, but
also other things.
Management and control
is about the same.
And then the driver takes care
of fare collection on bus.
But in rail, you
have people that
have to sort of be station
attendants and help people out.
You might have an office where
people can complain about their
needing a rebate because
their machine didn't
work or something.
They lost value on
their fare card.
So way maintenance
is more expensive,
whereas way maintenance
on buses on the streets,
that's not even included in the
cost for running bus systems
because that's--
the Public Works Department
takes care of that.
So overall, it's higher
for rail than bus.
But you have some--
yeah, so you do have a
higher productivity for metro
if you measure it in passenger
miles per revenue vehicle hour.
Yeah, so if you
have any questions,
I'll take them, questions on
the homework or on this lecture
or on the previous lectures.
And if you don't have
questions, you may leave.
AUDIENCE: Is that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You were
first, yeah, Scott.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] on slide
18 looking at capital cost
over passenger mile, do you need
to pick a time period in order
to make that calculation.
PROFESSOR: This is very general.
So this is sort of high level,
looking at the whole industry
and looking at like
capital projects.
So you know, if you look
at how much it costs
to build a new line, a new
light rail line in some city,
and then you see how many
people are taking it--
so we have passenger miles.
So you divide the total cost by
that, and that's what you get.
You have a question.
AUDIENCE: Yes, so regarding the
homework assignment, we are--
basically, we should do the
assignment and maybe comment
on, but assume that
we don't know--
we won't have like the--
what am I trying to say?
It seemed like there
was a lot of information
that you have already
asked if people
who are taking the train
the one stop that we are.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So we just assume
[INAUDIBLE] covered in the data
collection and assume
that that data exists,
but that we don't have it.
PROFESSOR: Yes, yes.
So there are people who--
I think what you're
referring to is
there are people
who are going to MIT
who get off at Central Square
and transfer to the Red Line,
right, and go to Kendall.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, especially
the Kendall area.
PROFESSOR: Right,
now how many of those
would continue on the bus
rather than switch anyway?
I'm not sure.
So there is a
judgment call there.
But yeah, we're focusing
on the people that
for sure would stay on the bus.
They're not
transferring to Kendall.
So they're going somewhere
else in that area
before reaching
Kendall possibly,
right, or almost surely.
And those are the people
that would definitely
stay on the bus.
AUDIENCE: That we talked to.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
yeah, exactly, which
is why we picked that bus stop.
But I think it's very likely
that, in a future assignment,
I will give you data on the
people who are transferring
to the Central Square Red Line.
And therefore, you'll
have the whole picture
of from your survey
and from the ODX data,
yeah, AFC data from Red Line.
AUDIENCE: Great.
PROFESSOR: Any other questions?
All right, goodbye.